ils sont des dizaines de milliers de
patients orphelins a enfin voir la
lumière au bout du tunnel parfois après
des années d'attenté selon québec plus
de 280 8000 patients sont désormais
inscrits auprès d'un groupe de médecine
de famille dépassant l'objectif de 250
mille personnes prises en charge que
s'était fixé québec mais dans quel délai
les patients auront c'est l'accès à une
consultation des médecins offrent de la
disponibilité
rapidement à leur clientèle inscrit donc
dans un délai de 0 36 72 heures pourtant
plus de 800 14000 québécois sont
toujours en attente aux guichets d'accès
à un médecin de famille ils étaient
quatre cent quatre-vingt mille lorsque
la cac est arrivé au pouvoir en 2018 une
hausse de 69% en quatre ans à l'époque
il y avait des gens qui s'inscrivait pas
sur la liste parce qu'il était tellement
convaincu que le poids de médecins de
famille pour félix antoine gingras c'est
le parcours du combattant
il attend depuis six ans qu'on lui
assigne un médecin de famille tout comme
son père dont la santé est
particulièrement fragile
j'ai 28 ans je suis en pleine forme
c'est peut-être moins graves mais encore
de mon père qui est que plus de 60 ans
qui est une santé était plus prêt cap
même en ce moment il ya le cancer du
poumon toujours pas de médecin de
famille sur twitter dominique anglade
qualif il annonce de shows de boucane
françois legault essaient de contourner
le problème en offrant des consultations
sans rendez-vous sans garantie de prise
en charge et de suivi dit elle
le prochain objectif est d'avoir un
total de cinq cent mille personnes
prises en charge en mars 2023 pour
l'atteindre québec mise sur un guichet
d'accès à la première ligne que devront
contacter ses patients ils vont appeler
à ce numéro de téléphone est le lieu une
infirmière qui va les évaluer et qui
vont
trier leurs besoins pour les orienter
vers le meilleur professionnel pour
répondre à la problématique
mais avec un déficit de 1000 médecins de
famille selon le docteur à millau cette
cible demeure un défi de taille ici et
me lemieux radio canada montréal